vise les sa basilique lieux remarquables
en bourgogne et peut-être futur grand
site de france
la colline éternelle est engagé depuis
six ans pour obtenir ce label décerné à
14 sites français une démarche de
qualité complémentaire de l'inscription
depuis 1979 au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
il s'agit de parvenir à une certaine
perfection ça vient s'ajouter aux autres
classements qui protège vézelay et le
site qui l'entourent mais ça permettra
vraiment de donner à la dimension
environnementale la place qui lui
revient et qui est fondamentale autour
de la colline de vezelay le label
récompense la préservation de
l'environnement et du patrimoine
pour l'obtenir vise les a donc engagé
des travaux de restauration de la
basilique
la seconde tranche a été lancé cette
semaine 6,9 millions d'euros jusqu'en
2020 un investissement pour l'avenir du
village pense qu'il est très important
de préserver le patrimoine c'est avant
tout à mon avis ce qui amène le tourisme
et de le restaurer d'y ajouter des fonds
à mon avis permet de garantir un certain
taux de touristes qui viendraient
visiter les les ici près d'un million de
visiteurs se pressent chaque année
mais vers l'est et les 17 communes
associées au projet rêve déjà d'un effet
grand site de france
les gens sont à leur charge deux choses
authentiques et cette nouvelle
classification être vraiment un gage
supplémentaire et les gens seront au
camp non à vsd ils viennent pas
disneyland mais qui viennent dans un
vrai endroit dans un vrai village où il
ya des vrais gens qui vivent ou il ya un
bassin économique où tout est protégé
tout est joli et tout se passe bien
si la candidature brésilienne est
acceptée ce serait le troisième grand
site en bourgogne avec la roche de
solutré et le mont beuvray
réponse attendue dans le courant de
l'année 2017